[Music]
my Instagram Jada Pinkett Smith is
looking hotter than ever on vacation
with her family in Italy this is my body
love it or leave it
the actress shared this sexy bikini pic
to Instagram after her hubby Will Smith
posted this video earlier in the day
Jada wasn't exactly feelin her look in
the clip so she mildly retaliated with
the sultry snaps writing quote since at
Will Smith got me looking all crazy in
his daddy dearest video I had to push
some counter-programming well the 46
year old actress might not love her
husband filming every minute of their
time together it's just a fun guy and I
think that this outlet just it's another
toy for him
she's never shied away from getting
candid about her personal life
especially on her Facebook watch series
red tabletop Jada who hosts the show
along with her mom Adrienne and daughter
willow recently sat down with et and
opened up about why she's decided to be
so candid I'm hoping that it will give
people the freedom also in their lives
to find their truth
[Music]
[Applause]